House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Devon Nunez is with us first do you have
any reaction to what you just heard from
John Solomon and I don't want to go to
his big breaking report from yesterday
yeah it doesn't surprise me Sean and we
have actively been looking into the
Clinton Foundation in uranium one if you
may remember that we assigned a task
force leader Peter King from New York to
look into this so we have seen some
troubling information on this and you
know I can't verify John's reporting he
always does a good job he has great
sources and I'm sure there's much more
to be learned on it let me go back to
his breaking news yesterday what we
discovered apparently and I don't know
how this was not known when we go back
two years now pretty much investigating
this whole issue the the Clinton bought
and paid for phony dossier etc what we
now found out there is an email chain or
a chain of emails James Comey is on it
top DOJ officials are on it and they
knew and the Intel committee had Intel
community had massive questions about
the veracity the truthfulness the
validity of the dossier which your memo
and the Grassley Graham memo point to as
the bulk of the applications for the
FISA warrant against quarter-page when
did you first find out about this email
chain well I don't know that the email
chain and John's reporting is the same
stuff that we're looking at although it
sounds very similar what we have been
saying and this is when as high as the
Speaker of the House we have been
requesting for many months now and
actually talked about it on your show a
couple weeks ago that there are there
are emails where there are Reid actions
that we are quite convinced that if that
is unredacted and provided to the House
of Representatives to the to the
Intelligence Committee it will be very
clear that there is very much it was
very well known that there was a lot of
information that was not provided to the
FISA Court leading up to the war the
warrant on Carter page so I don't know
exactly who John's sources are but I do
know that we have been trying to get
these read actions from emails without
look it's possible that we are we are
talking about the same types of emails
it's also possible Shawn that there's
even more emails that
you don't even know about but but what
we are aware of what I call the fourth
bucket of information it would be very
clear that there were people within the
FBI and DOJ that knew well and good
before they went to the FISA Court that
Christopher Steele and others were up to
some so you're saying the bad and
nefarious activity you say that these
emails will be the fourth bucket the
302s would be a second bucket
the FISA application themselves
especially the last one pages 10 through
12 17 to 34 then the gang of eight
information those would be the four
buckets what John is saying here that's
correct and and those worst three
remember Shawn in those first three the
the president has actually called to
have Declassified but he's holding we're
talking now recently said is this fourth
bucket okay so what I want to ask you is
if they knew and if the intelligence
committee knew that they were
questionable that the whole dossier was
questionable and it was the bulk of the
FISA applications and they used it
anyway we know that they omitted that
Hilary bought and paid for it with a
footnote that said it might be have a
political taint to it but they didn't
say it was the opposition party
candidate is it possible that they knew
it was not true that they gave it to the
FISA Court anyway that they didn't do
their due diligence verify and
corroborated and that they totally and
completely committed fraud on the FISA
Court not once before separate times
meaning anybody that signed off on it
was signing off on an application to spy
on an American with evidence that they
at best thought could very likely not be
true yeah so remember what we've been
looking at criminally has been abuse of
power whether or not there was a
conspiracy to abuse power you you know
about that you've talked about that for
a long time what this gets into is this
would be the first clear evidence that
we have on another major crime which
would be called lying to a federal judge
which is a crime in a major crime so
that is what the people we're talking
about it is the evidence that we have
this would be called me signing off on
it
rod Rosenstein signing off on the last
one that we have
I ate signing off on it right well
they're the ones that signed off on it
but they're not necessarily the ones who
would have provided and doctored the
information so really the people that
are culpable here are the ones who were
were in these discussions that knew
about the information that was not
provided to the court even though Adam
Schiff who I have a lot of issues with
will be the chairman of the committee
come January will you still have the
authority and the ability to get this
information to the American people yeah
I mean the only difference is is that I
will be the Republican leader on the
committee the question is is that the
subpoena power will lay in the hands of
the Democrats the Senate would have the
power to weaken that that's true but we
have also for many months here Sean been
willing to we've said that look our
investigations over with the White House
is going to be able to declassify a lot
of this information to help us out to
get to the bottom of this all right
congressman earnest you've done great
work so is John Solomon if so that
basically what I said is true that is
there is no equal justice equal
application of our laws that would be
shredding literally shredding if you're
giving false information to a court to
obtain a FISA warrant to spy on an
American and not even verifying it Wow